i know it's early i know that lots can
change before 2024 but i think as of
right now i have got a candidate this
man is saying all the right things he's
seeing things clearly and he is more in
touch with the american people than the
entire ruling class and that man's name
is chet hanks
so um just checking in look i've been
kind of on the fence about this for a
while that's why i've never spoke on it
but with the amount of people that i
know recently that have gotten coveted
and with like the numbers rising i think
it's important for me to say like
i got the vaccine
i think everybody should i think it's
really important like that we all do
this just as like citizens as americans
we have to look out for each other and
get this under control guys so like i
suggest to all my followers you guys
make set an appointment and get the
vaccine first things psych
if it ain't broke don't fix it i never
had kovitz yeah sticking me with that
[ __ ] needle it's the
[ __ ] flu
get over it okay if you're sick stay
inside i'm tired of having okay why are
we working around y'all if y'all uh if
you're in danger stay you're inside i'm
tired of [ __ ] man
brilliant articulate
so on the money i i love imagining that
that man is tom hanks's son he actually
is tom hanks's son there's much more to
dig into in chet hanks's political
philosophy but for those who doubt that
chet could be president keep in mind
that he now has a much much better
chance of becoming president than andrew
cuomo who resigned yesterday in disgrace
for all of the wrong reasons but he's
still gone republicans can chalk it up
as a win
but make no mistake the liberal
establishment still has all the power
before we move on from chet hanks we
will there are other things we have to
get to but i i can't tell you how much i
enjoy not only the fact that he's tom
hanks's son but the sorts of things he's
saying so tom hanks very famously very
liberal actor friends with obama
very
pro public health bureaucracy
the list goes on and on and chet
is not so a chet also after he posted
his his rant about covid posted another
one after he left a barnes and noble
where they told him to pull up his mask
so i'm sick of this man dude
flipping barnes and noble
buying books
check out my mask looks like a little
millimeter past my nostril oh sure you
gotta have your mouth oh yeah my bad not
bad
slips down again sir you're mad oh okay
my bad
i'm like i go i go you're really on it
huh he goes uh yeah we are
okay
he's like
did you get the vaccine i'm like yeah
yeah for sure i got the vaccine psych
if it ain't broke don't fix it i never
had kobe
so so the crazy thing about these jet
hanks videos is that he has more
credibility than dr fauci because chet
hanks uses some salty language and he
speaks in a way that's kind of vulgar
but
he hasn't gotten everything wrong about
kovic yes i'm not making any listen
youtube
overlords i'm not making any comment on
the vaccines i'm just saying that what
we know from dr fauci is that he has
gotten things wrong and wrong and wrong
again what we know from the liberal
establishment broadly is not not only
have they gotten things wrong but
they've actively misled us on multiple
occasions dr fauci admitted this when he
told us not to wear the masks and he
said we have to wear the mask and they
only told us not to wear the masks
because he wanted to save the mask for
his buddies
so chet hanks
i think representing something that we
saw come up with trump we've seen bubble
up a lot of times in american politics
which is that people who don't use the
jargon who don't go along with the
narrative who don't do what all of the
elite institutions tell us to do those
people seem to have their finger on the
pulse of the people and of reality a lot
better
i'm glad you liked that clip we got a
whole episode it's called sleazy
democrat gives the kiss of death you can
get it on youtube but you can also get
it at apple podcasts spotify google play
and stitcher head on over there right
now and subscribe to the michael knowles
show i'll wait
thanks for subscribing we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you